Если вы много работаете У вас Много
суеты много задач много дел но при этом
очень мало результатов и мы вы мало
чего-то добиваетесь в жизни то у вас
проблема со стратегией обязательно
досмотрите это видео до конца и я
расскажу что такое стратегия и как она
влияет на вашу жизнь Многие люди думают
что для того чтобы получать много
результатов Нужно больше двигаться а
больше выполнять задач больше работать и
так далее на самом деле сами по себе
беспорядочные хаотичные действия они
приносит результат результат приносит
именно целенаправленные чётко выверенные
действия а без стратегии этого
невозможно достичь ч всего я хотел бы
сказать что любые Ваши действия не
основанные на стратегии это просто суета
перед неудачей поэтому Давайте сегодня
разбираться что же такое стратегия и
понимать как она работает и как вы
можете применять её в своей жизни Многие
думают что стратегия - это просто планы
либо это какой-то технический термин
который применяется там а в каких-то
особых ситуациях и для людей стратегия
слово стратегия воспринимается чересчур
Сложно и они пытаются это как-то
избегать Но на самом деле стратегия -
это планируемая линия наиболее
эффективного поведения для достижения
ваших целей за счёт концентрации вашего
внимания на том что имеет наибольшую
важность В долгосрочной перспективе
Давайте по частям разберём это
определение что такое линия наиболее
эффективного поведения вот здесь
происходит основная лини линия
разделения между стратегией и планами
Вот давайте разберём Что такое планы Что
такое стратегия чтобы нам чётко
понимать разницу между ними так вот план
- это по сути список дел которые вы
выполняете в определённом порядке а
стратегия - это линия поведения это не
список дел это линия поведения вот чтобы
вам легче объяснить Например я вам
расскажу одну китайскую притчу вы же
знаете китайцы очень сильны в Стратегии
особенно вот в трактате о войне снз а
там говорит очень много про стратегию
так
вот был в китайском царстве один царь и
он ожидал нападения со стороны соседнего
царства он вызвал трёх генералов своих и
попросил выработать контрмеры против
нападения один генерал сказал я боевой
генерал Мы вяжем в войну я по опыту знаю
там на месте разберёмся на месте всё
становится виднее второй генерал говорит
Нет нужно строить оборонительные
укрепления нужно строить крепости нужно
быть непобедимым А дальше мы можем
достичь Победы а третий генерал говорит
я не буду предлагать что-то конкретное
но я знаю точно нам нужно держать высоты
нам нужно ограждать противника от
питьевой воды и нам нужно пользоваться
преимуществами местности и
преимуществами дня и ночи то есть что
получилось первый генерал предлагал
биться вообще без без никакого плана Это
как Вот часто бизнесмены знаете на
интуиции вот вижусь А дальше ситуация
покажет или война план покажет ещё часто
говорят второй генерал предлагал
конкретно сделать планы то есть оградить
периметр города построить стены этого
проект планы Что делать и так далее а
третий говорил не про планы не про
расходы потому что строительство оборони
сооружения - это всё-таки большие
расходы третий генерал говорил про линию
поведения вот линия поведения всё время
держать высоты всё время ограждать врага
от источников питьевой воды всё время
пользоваться возможностями дня и ночи и
так далее и так далее видите В чём
разница между стратегией и планами планы
- это конкретные Шаги а стратегия - это
линия поведения которая проходит через
всё все Ваши действия в том числе через
все ваши планы далее как мы говорили
стратегия - это планируемая линия
наиболее эффективного поведения для
достижения ши долгосрочных целей
стратегия всегда преследует достижение
вами долгосрочных целей она не
направлена на достижение ваших
краткосрочных целей Вот это нужно тоже
чётко понимать В то время как в планах
Вы очень часто ставите краткосрочные
цели за счёт чего же достигается это это
достигается за счёт концентрации вашего
внимания на самом главном на самом
важном Что такое самое главное Самое
важное смотрите многие люди делают очень
много действий и думают что сами по себе
действия приведут их к результату на
самом деле сами по себе действия не
приводят к результату они просто
увеличивают количество суеты и Хаоса в
вашей жизни вы просто по пусу тратите
свою энергию бега бегая туда-сюда
действия нужно делать только те которые
прямо влияют на достижение вами вашего
результата и такие действия называются
точками приложения усилий так вот
стратегия - это по сути концентрация
вашего внимания на точках приложения
усилий только на тех шагах которые
конкретно приведут вас к до срочным
вашим целям и именно в долгосрочной
перспективе то есть стратегия - это не
такая вещь при котором вы раз-два шага
сделали и получили немедленный результат
как правило стратегии дают долгосрочный
результат они не дают результат быстро
но зато они дают результат долгосрочный
очень важно выстраивать сначала
стратегию Потому что если вы вы не
выстраивается стратегию то вы как белка
в колесе Вы каждый день боретесь с
проблемами которые прилетают вам
ежедневно Если вы работаете на основе
стратегии то вам просто перестают
прилетать ежедневные проблемы и вы
занимаетесь более долгосрочными целями и
делайте это не спеша и вдумчиво
вспомните пожалуйста в своей жизни
ситуация Наверняка у вас были такие
ситуации когда вы делали делали много
дел разных действий выполняли задачи и
вдруг в какой-то момент раз и от
какого-то действия вы резко начали
получать результат то есть какое-то
действие оказало наибольшее влияние на
конеч результат Опишите пожалуйста это в
комментариях запомните такое действие и
такие действия - это и есть точка
приложения усилий вы просто интуитивно
Нажали на ту точку которая прямо влияла
на ваш результат А теперь Представьте
что для достижения ваших долгосрочных
целей существует там 1.000 задач которые
нужно выполнить Но если вы побежите
выполнять сразу же все 1.000 задач у вас
просто не будет хватать времени и
энергии на всё это Но если вы из этих
1.000 задач вычленить себе только в
ключевые точки приложения усилий на
которые надо давить чтобы моментально
получать продвижение к своей цели или
получать эффект то это и будет стратегия
стратегия - это по сути как я уже
говорил повторюсь это план работы только
по точкам приложения усилий для того
чтобы понять глубже понять что такое
стратегия и как её выстраивать Давайте
пройдёмся по нескольким основополагающим
принципам которые вы должны знать первое
Вы должны для себя усвоить чётко что в
этом мире нет ничего
изолированного всё в этом мире так или
иначе взаимосвязано друг с другом вы
даже не можете представить что-то
абсолютно отдельно стоящее всё является
частью нашей реальности второе Вы должны
понимать что все взаимосвязи которые
есть между людьми между людьми и вещами
или между объектами все эти взаимосвязи
они динамичны ничего не стоит на месте
Всё движется и эти связи не просто
динамичные эти взаимосвязи двигаются
только в двух направлениях они либо
улучшаются и процветают либо чаются и
умирают возьмём простые например ваши
взаимоотношения с друзьями так вот ваши
отношения с друзьями они всё время
подвижны какие-то отношения или
отношения с каким-то другом у вас
улучшаются с каким-то другом ухудшаются
но они всё время в движении или возьмём
ваши отношения с коллегами с партнёрами
у вас тоже эти отношения Либо улучшаются
либо ухудшаются е Если вы не общаетесь
отношения ухудшаются автоматически Если
вы чаще и глубоко общаетесь у вас
отношения улучшаются поэтому первые два
принципа - это то что в этом мире всё
взаимосвязано а второе все взаимосвязи в
мире динамичны они либо ухудшаются либо
улучшаются сразу вам дам небольшой
лайфхак для того чтобы управлять
взаимосвязями Если вы хотите чтобы ваши
отношения с друзьями родственниками или
коллегами улучшали а дам вам очень
хороший действенный лайфхак
взаимоотношения укрепляются и улучшается
только за счёт внимания то есть чем
больше внимания вы уделили вашим
взаимоотношениям тем лучше ваши
взаимоотношения вообще Внимание - это
такой Эликсир жизни как я называю У меня
даже формула есть по этому поводу что
внимание - это равно скобки открываются
это ваше время
А плюс ваша энергия скобки закрываются и
умноженная на любовь Если вы любые ваши
взаимоотношения делите время потратите
энергию и делать будете делать это с
любовью то любые ваши взаимоотношения
расцветут третий принцип о котором я
хотел бы поговорить А дело в том что в
этом мире А все взаимоотношения они
построены не просто так они построены А
на причинно-следственной связи все
взаимоотношения между людьми и объектами
между объектами и между людьми и людьми
они построены на причинно-следственной
связи возьмём например простые
взаимоотношения между человеком каким-то
объектом вот я могу взять этот компьютер
толкнуть он подвинется в автомобиле если
я нажму на ГАЗ он поедет нажму на тормоз
он остановится то есть всегда есть
причина и следствия возьмём ваши
отношения там с партнёром Если вы
поступите нечестно по отношению к
партнёру то ваши отношения ухудшится
если наоборот вы проявите внимание и
позаботились о партнёре ваши отношения
улучшится поэтому очень важно усвоить
этот третий принцип о том что
взаимоотношения они не просто динамичны
и не просто у них есть причины и
следствия а то что все взаимоотношения
они состоят из причинно-следственных
связей Не бывает ничего в мире просто
так и знаете это очень хорошая новость
потому что причинно-следственная или
понимание причинно-следственных связей
даёт нам понимание того На что надо
воздействовать для того чтобы получить
желаемый результат А мы ведь все имеем
цели Мы все имеем желаемый резу
и Наша задача - это найти именно вот эту
прямую связь между вашим действием
которая будет причиной и результатом
который вы получите в результате этого
действия Таким образом мы поняли что для
достижения любого желаемого результата
вам нужно сделать определённую причину и
этих причин может быть много и ваша
задача вычленить выделить самую ключевую
причину и когда вы поставите себе цель и
пишете все весь список действий которые
необходимо сделать для того чтобы
достичь этой цели вам нужно посидеть и
хорошо подумать какие именно действия
окажут наибольшее влияние на результат
на достижение этого результата здесь
сразу же скажу такой лайфхак вы знаете
как правило для достижения большинства
может быть всех ваших целей а достаточно
сконцентрироваться на тех действиях
которые ведут к рост ведь в конечном
итоге все наши цели они направленные на
рост потому что Что такое рост рост -
Это основное проявление жизни Везде где
же есть жизнь то растёт Везде где А
деградирует всё то умирает то есть весь
мир он делится на Жизнь и смерть человек
либо объект либо растение когда оно
начинает а деградировать отмирать и так
далее оно идёт к смерти также и человек
если он перестаёт
развиваться если он перестаёт расти то
он начинает деградировать и умирает а
если человек а развивается и растёт то
он начинает процветать тоже самое
происходит и в бизнесе бизнес если у
него прибыль растёт то он процветает
если у него прибыль падает то он
деградирует и приходит банкротство
поэтому по сути вот я вам сразу даю
стратегию да Для того чтобы определить
Какие действия являются ключевыми в
большинстве ваших целей это те действия
которые прямо влияют на рост например
возьмём любые ваши хотелки и желания
кто-то хохочет больше прибыли кто-то
хочет больше денег кто-то хочет а больше
счастья лучши взаимоотношения и так
далее и так далее если все эти цели
объединить и посмотреть их все
объединяет слово рост рост прибыли рост
бизнеса А рост количества
контактов Там и так далее и так далее
поэтому любые действия или любые цели
для того чтобы вот действия которые
ведущие к цели чтобы вычленить Какие из
них самые ключевые выделяйте те которые
прямо влияют на рост Вот вы в бизнесе
занимаетесь У вас ежедневно прилетает
кучу задач бухгалтерия там что-то не
справляется там прошёл произошёл
какой-то косяк ещё что-то и так далее и
так далее вы берёте список задач
смотрите А что из этого прямо влияет на
рост моей прибыли если в этом списке
этого нету то вы значит как белка Коле в
колесе крутите вы тогда берёте этот
список задач и первыми первые три пункта
ставьте три действия которые прямо
повлияют на рост вашей прибыли или
приведут к росту вашей прибыли таким
образом ежедневно делая как минимум три
действия которые ведут вас к росту в
какой-либо из сфер как правило приведут
к вам вас наиболее кратчайшим путём к
достижению ваших целей это и есть основа
стратегий Давайте приведу ещё один
пример когда вы например начинаете
бизнес вот Что является ключевым при
начале любого нового бизнеса многие как
правило начинают думать ну это Маркетинг
это продажи это HR это набор команды это
бизнес-план это бухучёт это надо уметь
разбираться В финансах и так далее и так
далее на самом деле это всё я бы так
сказал тактика планы и суета самое
главное Вы должны для себя определить
вот что вы должны чётко понимать что
бизнес - это марафон и в процессе
занятия бизнесом Вы обязательно будете
много раз совершать ошибки и падать нету
ни одного человека который сделал бизнес
или достиг бы какой-либо цели сразу и
причём я сейчас говорю не только про
бизнес это любой вид человеческой
деятельности Когда Вы начинаете любой
вид человеческой деятельности вас
неизбежно ждут ошибки и определённые
провалы стратегически самое важное с
самого начала начинать только то дело
при котором вы будете каждый раз
вставать после падения А какое это дело
может быть это может быть только то дело
которое вы любите Если вы хотите начать
бизнес то прежде всего нужно
определиться и найти то дело в котором
Если вы будете падать Вы у вас будет
хватать энергии и мотивации заново
вставать и двигаться дальше Вот это
номер один стратегическая задача при
начале или
старте нового бизнеса вторая
стратегическая точка приложения усилий
можно сказать это то чтобы
найти такой бизнес желательно Если вы
например его даже не сильно любите но
который давал бы немедленную отдачу то
есть быструю отдачу Потому что когда вы
получаете от бизнеса либо от любой вашей
цели быструю отдачу то эта быстрая
отдача даёт вам силы и энергию и
мотивацию продолжать дальше таким
образом Если вы хотите начать новый
бизнес или любое новое дело вы должны
сконцентрировать внимание на двух вещах
первое выбрать то дело
которым вы готовы будете заниматься
невзирая на неудачи А это как правило
любимое дело или любимое занятие или
второе то дело которое даст вам
немедленную отдачу благодаря которой
ваша мотивация и энергия будет на
высоком уровне и она будет поддерживать
вас во время ваших падений вообще вопрос
ошибок и падения - это достаточно
большая тема самое главное Вот вы должны
тоже ещё усвоить такую вещь что падение
никогда не бывает плохим А и и вы
никогда не станете лузеров или
неудачником от того что упали вы станете
лузеров или неудачником если упали и не
встали а если после каждого падения вы
встаёте то у вас есть огромный шанс
стать победителем и ещё очень важно
находиться в правильной среде и общаться
с правильными людьми и получать
правильную информацию или правильные
знания Если для вас это актуально
переходите в мой Telegram канал Я как
раз там делюсь с очень многими
лайфхаками и жизненными историями ссылка
на мой Telegram канал в описании под эти
видео для того чтобы ещё сильнее
закрепить наше понимание стратегии для
чего она нужна Я вам приведу буквально
несколько таких мыслей или лайфхаков
чтобы вы глубже прониклись что это такое
стратегия если сказать по-простому это
мудрость превращённая в план вот
смотрите когда мы что-то делаем нас ждёт
очень много неопределённости и мы не
понимаем С какими препятствиями мы лкм и
предусмотреть все сценарии и все
варианты невозможно Единственное что мы
можем предусмотреть - это то как мы
будем реагировать и действовать в этих
ситуациях и это называется линия
поведения так вот линия поведения должна
основываться на мудрости стратегия - это
мудрость превращённая в план То есть у
вас есть мудрость жизненный опыт
мудрость понимание как себя вести в
разных ситуациях вы вырабатывать эту
линию поведения которая является
стратегией а потом на основе этого вы
составляете план и и тогда в вашем плане
есть место для изменений вы всегда
можете его подкорректировать изменить не
отклоняясь от вашей цели ещё один момент
хотел бы упомянуть что смотрите бизнес
без стратегии - это суета перед неудачей
любой бизнес - это всё-таки марафон и
это долгосрочная история поэтому вы для
себя тоже должны усвоить что бизнес без
стратегии - это суета перед на удачи А
вот что же такое инвестиции инвестиции
без стратегии это игра в казино вот для
тех кто Думает что он инвестирует или
занимается инвестициями и так далее на
самом деле вы занимаетесь трейдингом
Если у вас нету стратегии Если у вас
нету инвестиционной декларации своей в
которой выражается ваша инвестиционная
стратегия то вы скорее всего играете в
казино возьмём Что такое план без
стратегии план без стратегии - это
просто список дел это просто список дел
который не объединён ничем общим или не
объединён а линии наиболее эффективного
поведения Вы должны понимать что
стратегия - это линия поведения в
условиях или модель поведения в условиях
неопределённости И когда вы хотите
достичь любых успехов или любых целей то
вы должны взаимодействовать с
неопределённость потому что успеха
обычно не бывает там где всё ясно И всем
Всё понятно там до вас уже много людей
потоптались а успех всегда возможен там
где что-то неясно где есть риски
стратегия - это модель поведения в
условиях неопределённости стратегия -
это не только про то что делать это ещё
про то как делать когда делать где
делать с кем делать И зачем делать
поэтому стратегия гораздо глубже чем
большинство людей понимает Я вам
предлагаю сразу же после этого видео
подумать над тем Есть ли у вас стратегия
в вашей жизни вообще какие у вас
долгосрочные цели Возьмите и разбейте
свою жизнь на долгосрочные цели
пятилетние цели десятилетние цели и
причём в этих целях вы можете написать
три вещи я вам даю лайфхак как
достаточно просто создать свою стратегию
вы берёте на промежутке 5-10 лет
Например можно и на 20 лет сделать
промежуток и составляете три списка
первый список вы
пишете цели кем я хочу быть через 5 лет
через 10 лет через 20 лет
список Ну я говорю список это может быть
1Д три пункта второй список - это что я
хочу иметь через 5 лет через 10 лет
через 20 лет и третий - это чем я хочу
заниматься через 5 лет через 10 лет
через 20 лет и когда вы
поставите три вида таких целей по сути
это уже половина стратегии То есть вы
знаете а куда идти и чего достигать
после этого
Напишите список того что обязательно
нужно сделать чтобы добиться этих целей
то есть без чего эти цели невозможны и
когда вы это пропишите как правило это и
будут те ключевые действия которые вы
должны будете выполнить или обязательные
условия достижения вами этих целей Ну а
дальше поразмышляйте поразмышляйте над
тем что прямо влияет на рост вашего
состояния От текущего в будущем как
правило все ваши цели разница между вами
текущей с вашим текущим состоянием
состоянием кто вы сейчас что вы имеете И
чем вы занимаетесь и тем что вы кем вы
хотите стать Что вы хотите иметь и чем
заниматься разница только в росте то
есть в масштабе вам нужно вырасти
никогда не бывает таких целей когда вам
нужно упасть все ваши цели направлены на
то чтобы расти так вот ежедневно просто
ежедневно в свой список дел включайте
как минимум три задачи которые прямо
Ведут к вашему росту всё что влияет на
ваш рост и будет вашей стратегией